[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 momenthouse.com tinymeatgang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
uh so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.com
why don't we go through all the
characters and just um you know
rate their bodies i'm kidding let's go
through all the characters mark
zuckerberg
you're a four and just you're free just
so we can get to know
the uh their names
i'm not a very big name you're you're a
name guy yeah okay somehow
i don't know wild yeah how many times
we've done vips and i'm like oh what's
up
sean yeah like somebody'll be like like
a show and someone
or even in the crowd like we're at a
show and you recognize someone that was
at a previous show
oh you're steve right there they're even
like dude
uh that's kind of sauce i'm like yeah i
have you in my wallet
i have our picture of us in our wa in my
wallet
these are your feet right yeah what how
did you get that
well when you were at the last vip you
were in sandals
and i had our photographer you know
skin match so it's just fine it's
details it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter these are your friends
these are your feet it's confirmed these
are your feet and these are your toes
right i mean
these are them right oh sultry little
piggies
all right so this is kev kaz fashion
blogger right so she was the one that
said
she wants to get yeah she don't see a
rail get railed yeah
i think sex is an important part of any
relationship and i think everyone
needs it yeah can't argue with that she
said i want a guy to rail me can't argue
with that
all right kaz uh who do we got next
so scroll down brad yeah brad
this guy is almost like good looking
do you know what i'm saying yeah he he
looks like a video game character as
well yes
[ __ ] look at the [ __ ] dick veins
he's got no bro
this to me is like when you create a
character in a on like your nintendo ds
and then you scan
your kid face onto an adult body yes
yeah yeah like that's like a 12 year old
playing the love island game on ds yeah
like
took a picture of himself i was like
that's me that's not you man
you can't even do 10 push-ups also when
he said laborer as his job
alina and i thought he said i'm a libra
oh that's what i thought he said too
i'm 26 i'm a laborer what is a laborer
a labor laborer what is that like a
construction maybe
guy yeah i don't i don't know but you
know what was funny is when he mentioned
that
faye elena and i busted up laughing
because faye immediately like
he's um she's like what you do i'm labor
she goes ah
yeah it's just like immediate
oh another dumb hot guy i'm a cancer
[Laughter]
yeah she's like no no i'm a laborer
she's like i heard you i heard you
i'm not saying we're not compatible
unfortunately
oh yeah that [ __ ] killed me he's like i
live with me nana
every american watching that is like you
live with a banana what the
f what are you talking about dude
this show sucks dude this guy lives with
a banana and he's a libra
why does this you like this show so much
it's so whack
[Laughter]
yo look at this guy's dick van look at
the veins going into his
shorts like where do those even come
from the sole intention of those veins
are to
fuel your boner that's it that's what
happens when you take
just enough gas station pills
you get the pump straight to your dick
okay bro it kills me is like when he was
in the gym he maxed out his lat stats
he didn't care about anything else yeah
lats 99
all right i'm moving on who's next um
okay this is great shannon former glam
model
for what are you now she said she's a
twitch streamer oh right
she's like i play card i'm quite good
yeah yeah yeah i do hot tub streams well
it's hilarious is when she brought up
that she plays
cod and she's really good at games the
dude aaron
was like cool
it was the first time i've seen a dude
hear a woman say i play games and
he didn't perk up he like bullied her
for being a nerd almost like he's like
cool she might as well said she was a
laborer yeah yeah he's like ah
he's like you're a gamer right and just
walks away
i'm the first guy ever not to think
that's cool
yeah just it was like crazy games like a
child
yeah i've got a nephew he plays games so
like that
she's like yes it's proper fun quite
good
you know what's funny is i didn't hear
what she said when she was and i had to
like
ask kelsey what did she say she was and
kelsey was like she plays call of duty
like just knowing that i'm like what
that's sick
i'm surprised she didn't [ __ ] oh
she's a car this is my favorite dude
she's my
favorite she's so cool so cool
i couldn't believe that just didn't his
eyes didn't
move at that wow and i know every nerd
watching this was like
you these games dude yeah dude you don't
know what you have
to [ __ ] wrong
she's a queen
are you gone
this is my five million dollar
manchester flat
and the five million dollar part is my
twitch stream enjoying phase
phase shannon yeah uh this is aaron he's
24
and he thinks gamers are stupid
i'm aaron i'm 24 and i think gaming is
for idiots
shannon may have met oh shannon may have
met her match and aaron who is always
traveling abroad for work
sick my man events host oh yeah she he
like he does like night
night life [ __ ] yeah he's like uh you
know one of the socialites
yeah it's like i do vip event oh my god
i read that quote before i read the
sentence before go up what do you say go
up a little bit
that last sentence i banged them out on
a regular basis
oh and then i read that what it said
before aaron said his worst habit is
farting yo i like
did see why didn't they put that in the
interview yeah
then we would have had some like real
[ __ ] to go into so yeah kaz was like i
love getting railed
yeah jake's like i love suckling toes
you go to this dude and he's like i'm
always farting
every i bang them on the regular every
dude been like my boy
yeah that's my boy right there i bang
them out when i'm banging out
oh oh wonderful now what was the
yeah yes quite
quite commensurate
[Music]
[Laughter]
so aaron doesn't like gamers what else
who else else we got here moving all
right wake up
shannon she's a sharon sharon that's
that's
a servant sharon's the smart one yep uh
go away go up again so prior to this she
was a beauty queen and landed the title
of miss international uk oh rot
sharon's type is tall dark and willing
to put me in line if i'm too sassy or
straightforward
whatever whatever that means whatever
that means okay keep going
so she's the smart one yeah and then we
got hugo
aka gumby all right say you're sorry to
go i'm sorry dude the hugo
no because he's a nice guy no he is
i think he's just two nights just a
different show he should be on the bat
the uk version of the bachelor yeah yeah
if he was like that guy yeah
oh dude kill it yeah oh my god his p.e
teacher
yeah wants to help people yeah the youth
yeah unless bro what if this next
episode he just like comes out
he is savage like he's like
he's never gonna look at me the same
yeah like he's an absolute cocksman
yeah yeah nice yeah yeah absolutes uh
uh damn i absolute sausage slinger
yeah there you go there you go um
he admitted he's never asked a girl to
call him mr hammond
i have nothing i could do without
laughing i just told him to call me
daddy
yeah that's the second half of the quote
all right
let's move on um chloe so this is the
girl that
oh i got i got i got their names wrong i
said
i said sharon was chloe earlier but she
is sharon
wait sharon isn't chloe the one that
came in at the end
or not yeah yeah yeah so that is close
i'm just saying so we haven't met her
yet
no okay i [ __ ] sharon's name up though
yeah that's all it's okay i mean bro
she's
like she look i think she looks she
looks like she was 6'1 in those shoes
the girl that came into the sharon yeah
this is the oh sharon yes yeah
she knows she did she was she was
talking to whoop my ass yeah yeah
i know for sure yeah so actually being
in civil war yeah is awesome it's really
cool
yeah i mean that's really nice that's a
really great thing to do
we think you're going to go very far on
the show please don't come in you're so
smart you're so smart
nonsense might have you seen much yes
there's nothing she could do
so yeah i think you know obviously
obviously
it's hard to like really you know get
into it because there's not a lot has
happened but like next week i feel like
it's going to be
proper trauma yeah do you know no
there's jake the water
yeah what the [ __ ] is a water engineer
uh ian sterling kept
cooking him calling him a plumber oh by
the way by the way
is that what it is i think so okay by
the way his commentary was
[ __ ] on point hilarious so funny i
laughed out loud multiple times yeah at
this episode
shout out ian man i can't remember the
funniest bits but
i want to see i also had one more thing
written down i'm
i'm now i'm just getting all the pen oh
yeah when she
when sorry when liberty and him were
flirting
like like near the end of the episode
and she was like i like you
you're so like goofy and he's like goofy
i'm not goofy no not me i'm not goofy
i was like dude calm the fight buddy
somebody called him that in childhood he
did not like that [ __ ]
yeah he's like goofy no that's not here
he had a traumatizing uh time at disney
disneyland or he won the london disney
world or whatever
no i think goofy it must have been like
some girl of his dream situation she
called him goofy yeah
just never again that's why he's so
yolked yeah he like worked his hair like
that
i'm not goofy yeah he put on that hole
for like no
that whole shell and one girl sees right
through it she's like no you're goofy
what [ __ ] not me what
what'd you say i'm cool i'm cute
i'm cool i'm cool so this is the guy i
was talking about so like not
like you know i i wouldn't say he's like
crazy
you know attractive by any means i mean
he's definitely a good looking guy but
i think that his [ __ ] he's he's gonna be
the funny one
no he's gonna have the chat he's gonna
have the banter yeah that's the girls
are going to fall in love with him
that's why i think in castlemore he's
going to be like
a disc a hound not even i think he's
going to be like a show dog
or like not even like a hunting dog like
just off his leash
yeah just picking up a deep sense you
know sling a joke here sling a joke
there's and just you know
see what see what pops off where yeah
that dude that moment when liberty
uh was like i get my looks from me mom
she looks really good for her age and
then jake's like i wish i could meet
your mom
and suck a toad i'm like this dude has
like like when you
clip out all these small comments yeah
i'm like this dude is horny as [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah he is
it's like probably him and kaz would be
a good pair
yeah yep because he's horny yeah
like you know like hidden in plain sight
horn yeah
and she's like yeah i'll be pinned yeah
that dude i feel like they're gonna have
a few drinks and one night he'll just
lean
he's a hound he's a horn dog i bet could
suck your toes better than toby
what what i would lick your toes
lick
and then we got faye yeah crazy eyes
yeah lettings manager what is a lettings
manager face said she wants somebody who
who can literally
rip her a new [ __ ] i mean then she
goes well not like that lit
oh like not lit literally not literally
oh yeah her whole thing was uh you know
i'm
i'm fiery um this and that so she
i mean i i don't like her already like i
just her personality she's like
clearly i feel like she's never been
told no so she was like even at the
beginning was really
uh like offended when the guy didn't
when when toby
oh and aaron aaron was aaron yeah it was
aaron he's okay she stepped forward for
aaron
and aaron picked another girl and she
was like well he didn't even remember my
name so i dodged a bullet
yeah yeah and then and then when kale or
the [ __ ] other guys
the brad guy also forgot her name she
didn't say [ __ ] no he was like oh to the
blueberry
yeah and she was like okay come over
here
so i don't know incel is gonna clip out
that moment it's a double standard
no i mean i just it could have been the
guy like i'm it doesn't matter
i'm saying she i could tell like she she
was a little bit like in her she's a
little bit abrasive throughout the whole
show
like she never really was charming to me
no i mean like when
when uh the brad dude was talking i
don't know if it was just editing but it
didn't seem like
she was trying to talk to him yeah she
was just letting him go and then
complaining after the fact like
yeah yeah and staring just she's doing
the chuck e cheese eyes
never never even saying anything or
asking a question that's probably why
he's talking in circles
like it's like quite nice because i'll
get to know each other yeah and she's
just like
just analyzing his face he's like
detected like i said we can get to know
each other
the show will start in three minutes
you don't want to miss the pizza bash i
brought nate
you watched nate baragatsu's new special
nice outside oh he's got such a great
bit about chuck e cheese basically about
how they've been trying to go out of
business but they can't
they're like trying to be a blockbuster
they just they can't like for some
reason just
they keep surviving so none of this [ __ ]
works anymore
the pizza's recycled and it's just
so funny he's like just parents drinking
at like nine in the morning and
i'm not seeing any ubers taking those
kids home
i'm butchering it go watch his special
it's [ __ ] phenomenal he's like my
favorite comedian ever
what is this this is the video that i
sent out but this is like it doesn't
matter trailer doesn't kind of nail this